What's your take on using bovine organ concentrates?
So bovine organ concentrates is an organ tissue.
So organ tissue became very common use,
a nutraceutical back in the 1960s, really.
Maybe even before that, some companies
came out with, and I know, biotics, research,
and standard process where the two companies
that really started using organ concentrates,
they can be extremely beneficial.
So one of the belief systems with organ concentrates
is that when an organ is, let's say, hurting.
So let's say your thymus gland needs help to keep up,
so one of your things that your thymus gland
does is it helps stimulate immune function.
So your thymus gland may need help
and keep it up with the immune response, let's say.
Your thymus gland actually secretes messenger RNA.
Well, a lot to be heard about messenger RNA
this last year with these vaccinations.
Well, messenger RNA is made by your body.
So we're not talking about a messenger RNA drug
that's called a vaccine that's projected in you
to do bad things to yourselves.
Your healthy cells release messenger RNA
to tag something that will be helpful for that cell.
So messenger RNA travels to your broadened gland.
It's released in your saliva.
And when you are exposed to any nutrient
that's gonna help that organ,
message that messenger RNA tags that nutrient
from the saliva,
it travels down to your stomach,
tags it as you absorb it,
and it will help bring it to that organ
to help that organ heal.
The other benefit of glandulars
is that a person has an autoimmune attack on a certain gland.
Let's say they have an autoimmune attack on the thyroid.
By you taking thyroid glandulars,
you're actually the autoimmune attack is happening partly
on that organ glandular that you're consuming
and out of the thyroid itself.
So it can help calm down an autoimmune attack.
But we're not treating autoimmune disease here.
We're treating cancer.
So can organ glandulars be beneficial for cancer?
So let's say if a person has ovarian cancer,
can take this product like cytosolium,
fb beneficial where it has an ovary tissue in it?
There's, I did write a blog post about this several years ago,
using organ glandulars for cancer.
There's a lot of,
there's several studies that are out there.
And there's a lot of theory that's out there
that it can be beneficial by using the glandular
of the tissue that you have the cancer with,
that it can help the body respond better
and help that tissue heal better.
So has it been proven out with our testing?
Not always.
We do use these products.
I like biotics research.
Gladiulars, especially because they're all,
all their glandulars also have superoxid dismutase
and canolase with it,
which are really strong into accidents.
They help protect the glandular for many years
beyond the expiration date,
but they also help protect the glandular substance
when it's brought into the body.
And if it is brought to the tissue site,
especially for cancer cells,
let's say if I have cancer in my ovaries
and I'm taking ovarian tissue here,
the site as I have half,
then it's gonna be brought there with the SOD and canolase.
So you have that antioxidant benefit
that you're carrying directly to the cancer itself.
So I'm a big fan of using glandulars.
Now, the argument that people say is,
well, this is no fine tissue
and I'm supposed to be off of meat.
You don't need to worry about this.
This is this organ tissue.
And this is not muscle tissue of the cow.
So bovaid means cow.
This is also taken from organically grown cows.
No, they're still exposed to chemicals
no matter what you do,
but as clean as you can get.
So bietic researchers has a very strong reputation
with their glandulars
and they're a company that I trust a lot.
They've been doing this for many, many years.
So bovaid organic glandulars are great.
The problem is is they don't have them for everything.
Standard biotics has the greatest array of them
in their stock, but they don't have every single tissue
but they have maybe more 15 different tissue glandulars
so they can be very beneficial.
Typically, from a functional medicine standpoint,
glandulars are used to help stimulate that organ
using thyroid glandulars can be very helpful
with a person with hypothyroidism
using adrenal glandulars can be very helpful for somebody
who has dealing with stress issues,
dealing with low thyroid issues.
This product is thigh, this doesn't stand for thyroid,
this stands for thymus.
So this would be an immune stimulator, this cytosine thigh.
And the f stands for female here
and that has ovary, has pituitary,
has hypophelmas, ovary, and I think uterine tissue in there,
but that's a great balance formula for women.
So gladulars can be great tissues,
things to add to their product life.